as I've said many times man I am a
really big fan of your work and I just
want to say thank you for doing what you
do thank you very much that's very nice
I am a huge fan of Michael man just like
you if someone has not seen any Michael
Man movies take away Ferrari because
obviously they should go see it what's
the first thing they should watch and
why oh that's hard because they're very
different
uh I mean heat heat is uh probably the
first one yeah yeah yeah uh Ian I could
go in order maybe I don't know heat and
I would say The
Insider last micans I mean Thief I'm
just naming all the heat I'd say heat uh
speaking of heat So you you're working
with Michael you're on the set uh
obviously he too came out when you were
making the film I believe how much are
you whispering in his ear Michael I'm a
really big fan of heat did you know I
like heat cuz I heard I heard you're
making a sequel no we were all Ferrari
we were all engrossed in Ferrari sure
just throwing that out there I am so
curious so you obvious you're very
talented actor but but what is the the
the before the night before the first
day of filming something what has been
the most nervous you've been that night
before on what project hard to hard to
say hard hard to say I yeah I don't I
don't know
um yeah I usually had troubles I think
earlier in
um uh in my career I had um I I would
have tough a tough time going to sleep
but that doesn't happen uh now I'm more
I'm more excited to get this set the
first day whereas before I was really
nervous but and I'm still nervous but
I'm I'm I I want to I want to get into
it you obviously spent a lot of time
working with Michael for fans of Michael
man what actually surprised you about
working with him so closely on Ferrari
and what was it about this project that
said I I need to do this Michael
uh when he sent it to me I I didn't I I
could read it and I acknowledge that it
was well written but I didn't uh find a
connection to the character but uh but
then in I found with Michael the
surprising thing to answer the first
part of your question is I was surprised
to find out how much he's invested in
internal life uh he he is obviously
famous for you know well researched and
all of those things but he uh is uh
fascinated by internal life and the
power of thought to him is very
cinematic I mean even in that scene in
heat that you know people don't have a
lot of time sometimes in his movies to
make these big turns but their internal
lives are so rich and so specific then
that that's why you can rewatch them
over and over and over again all of his
notes are about character and internal
life my last question for you because I
think I'm going to be out of time I
could not be more excited for cop's new
movie which you got to be a part of uh
what can you say about working on his
his passion project which he literally
financed himself because he financed it
himself it it made the shooting process
uh one of the best experiences if not
the best shooting experience I've ever
had there was uh no excess conversation
there was no uh uh you know people
robbing from Peter to pay Paul not not
even just the financial part of it it
just it felt like a he was in control of
the movie that he wanted to make and
that was it it it felt like oh this is
how movies should be and he is the most
uh generous you know philosophical
person that I uh that that I know I I
loved that uh process uh and making with
him I love talking to him it it I I
could I know we were like out of time
it's hard to answer these in the in um
uh in a short amount of time but it it
was one of it's an the movie is wild
it's it's so imaginative and uh big and
epic and uh is saying something really
uh uh uh and it's bold that that's the
it takes a risk and I I couldn't be more
excited by it have you seen footage mhm
yeah yeah do he show you a rough cut I
know I got to go I will not
say I'll stop there but it's amazing
it's amazing I I cannot wait to see it
and I wish you nothing but the best
thank you very very
much